everyone this is coming from the chess
website calm today we're going to be
continuing our series on trading pieces
and when to trade pieces and when not to
trade pieces and in the first video we
touched on a very important key concept
and that is when you're up material and
you can trade down to a winning in game
go ahead and do that that's a good time
to trade down a material today we're
going to be going over two more concepts
when to trade them when not to trade and
the first one is if you have a spatial
advantage if you look at here white has
a very distinct spatial advantage
there's not much black can do as far as
development Mike's kind of trapped in
and white has a lot of room that they
can move develop light can castle can
bring his his queen connecting the rooks
a lot of different play that white can
do where black doesn't have that so what
black would want to do because he has a
spatial disadvantage is he would like to
trade off as many pieces as you can
where white is not going to want to
trade off pieces if we take all the
pieces off except the pawns white no
longer has quite the advantage obviously
he has three more pawns pushed a little
farther but it's really not a big
advantage but here white has a huge
advantage because he has such a big
spatial ban so in this case white would
not want to trade off pieces and black
would because it would kind of alleviate
some of the pressure so that's one of
the concepts that you should always
think about if you're applying pressure
on your opponent and
you're kind of squeezing down and they
don't have a lot of space to move you
really don't want to trade off pieces
and on the flip side if you're being
squeezed and you can trade off pieces
then that will kind of give you
alleviate some of that pressure that
your opponent's putting on you so that's
the first one we're going to go ahead
and take a look at the second aspect of
trading the next thing to consider when
trading is if trading will make one of
your existing pieces more powerful then
go ahead and trade if you take a look at
this example for white and if you recall
from a couple videos ago the outpost
video if you look at the square right
here this e six boy is a very powerful
outpost so we would like our knight to
get to the square or a bishop it's a
very powerful output so with that in
mind where should white move take a
moment pause if you need to figure out
what Y should do to control the square
right here and hopefully you just come
up with a move Bishop to h3 now the
bishop can move to e8 but it's going to
be the same effect the knight is going
to eventually come to the e6 square so
black can trade off bishops here and
white can now regain and eventually
we're going to put our knight here on
the e6 square and it's a great outpost
as you can recall from past videos when
you can get a knight deep into your
opponent's territory and he can't be
captured if you look at the Black Knight
it's actually going to take in three
different moves to get to our knight on
e6 and black just doesn't have that much
time we're attacking the
the rook on f8 we're attacking the Queen
on d8 and we have just so many possible
attacks from this all because of our
trade that we made with our Bishop from
the h3 square so again you may look at
this and say hey you know we traded
equal material but our knight is so much
better because of the trade that this is
a good trait for us so we'll go ahead
and take a look at another example of
this now on those same concepts it's
black smooth what would you do go ahead
and take a minute and look at it and
hopefully if you've been following my
videos for some time now especially the
middlegame strategies hopefully some of
the concepts that I've been going over
are starting to come a little quicker
you're starting to look at stuff and say
hey I see outpost here hey I should move
here if things are coming to you quicker
that means you're becoming a better
chess player so in this move hopefully
right off the bat you just saw that
there's a great outpost here on the d4
square and as you probably saw hopefully
very quickly this night here on f3 is
defending this outpost on the d4 square
so our best move is going to be to pin
the knight down on f3 and then we can
trade off there's nothing we white can
do here because he can't lose his Queen
so I'll just make a random move here for
white and once we capture no matter how
he recaptures we can bring our knight
here to the d4 square we have a great
outpost
there's nothing white can do to knock
this Knight off of the d4 square as you
can see the bishop is a light square
bishop you can hakama the only way to
knock them off is to lose material and
this Knight here can attack many
different places and can basically just
sit here all game until he's ready to
attack so hopefully as we're progressing
in these examples they're coming to you
quick and you're learning quite a bit
those are the three things you need to
remember when thinking about trading the
first one is if you're up a great deal
of material trade down to winning in
game just simplify things for yourself
two is if you have a spatial advantage
you should trade down or you excuse me
you should not trade down if you have a
spatial disadvantage you should trade
down and the last one if trading down
will give one of your existing pieces
make it more powerful than go ahead and
tray down so hopefully you guys enjoyed
the videos on when to trade and when not
to trade and look out for some more
coming in the near future thanks a lot
guys